Uh-oh.
Oh.
Hi.
Oh, hello, Kate.
I love the smell of manure.
It reminds me of my childhood.
Is that poop?
Oh, yeah.
Paint the best picture of
a horse whilst riding a horse.
You may only paint when
your horse is in motion.
So, wait a minute.
That means I have
to ride a horse?
Yeah.
How is your horse riding?
It's not good.
Happy getting you on a horse?
Uh... Yeah, why not?
Am I going to be strapped in?
Strapped in?
Yeah.
I don't think so.
No.
Let's do it.
Let's ride a horse.
Good luck.
Thanks.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Now we're going to see
everyone except
for Freddie paint on a horse.
Oh, that's excellent.
Alex, how do you
make the color brown?
I'd probably just use brown.
Yeah, well you didn't
give me brown.
You're painting Ebony there.
Ebony? Beautiful name
for a beautiful horse.
Are you enjoying yourself?
Oh, are we running a little?
Oh, my God.
Okay, there we go.
Well, I've lost Ebony.
There we go,
that's a horse face.
You're not looking
at the model.
Oh, yeah, I forgot.
My bad.
Yah.
We're going to run?
Okay, okay, whoa, what, what?
How's your painting going?
Huh? It's good.
I think I got a lot
of paint on me.
I forgot what the challenge is.
Ow, ooh, oh, ah, oh.
I just peed.
[ Laughter ]
You guys know it's not easy
to paint on a horse?
I'm never having children, now.
I mean, I'm a natural.
That looks like a horse.
A green one.
It's abstract, you douchebag.
[ Laughter, cheering, applause ]
What is a douchebag?
We don't have them.
Is it a good thing?
Not in that context because,
as you know,
I freaking hate you.
Yes.
Before you see the pictures,
I should tell you
that Ron spent four times
as long on the horse
as anyone else.
Wow.
I mean, if you're going to
give me a free horse ride
I'm going to take advantage.
Okay, so strap yourselves in.
These are the four horses.
I think Dillon did
an interesting job
because it's kind of like
a Transformers robot.
Yeah.
Dinosaur?
Do you want to look
at Ron's close up?
Beautiful.
Yeah, so what I notice
immediately,
it's like you've just ordered
a hamburger in your wrapper,
and you look down,
and you're like,
"Oh, it kind of looks like some
kind of a animal of some sort."
You get what I was going for.
It's very good and very...
Yeah, you can stop talking.
It's a...
Kate's looks a bit like a horse,
which is good because it's Kate.
Yeah. What I like about Kate's
is that some of the paint
is running off of the page,
which indicates that it's
bleeding in to our own reality,
which is interesting.
There's one picture left.
There's the weeping horse
of Lisa Lampanelli.
I like that her and horse
has the same dye job.
Yes, yes, yes.